merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole et à monsieur patrice verchère
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre le 14 avril
dernier le président de la république
posait les jalons de sa nouvelle
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
par un tonitruant
oui ça va mieux depuis il répète sa
formule à qui veut bien l'entendre
c'est probablement ce qu'on appelle le
comique de répétition à un an des
élections françois hollande réendosse
donc son costume de monsieur petites
blagues mais ne nous y trompons pas les
frais les français et jaune
il se demande alors ce qu'ils écoutent
françois hollande dans quel monde il vit
pas dans le leurre assurément pas dans
un monde normal
étrange paradoxe un président qui se
voulait le garant de la normalité
car les chiffres sont têtus monsieur le
président depuis quatre ans le chômage a
fortement progressé dans notre pays
alors qu'il a reculé de manière
significative chez nos voisins en fait
brillant 1 février 2016 il a atteint son
niveau le plus haut depuis 1997 et le
chômage des jeunes a quant à lui dépassé
les 25 % depuis quatre ans monsieur
féministe et français sont accablés
d'impôts la baisse de la pression
fiscale n'a été réelle que pour ceux qui
en paient déjà peu tandis que les
classes moyennes et supérieures
concentre encore un peu plus le poids
des impôts et des taxes en tous genres
quand la crise de 2008 n'est plus qu'un
mauvais souvenir chez nos voisins
européens la france reste englué dans
une croissance toulon largement
inférieure à celle de la zone euro
la france n'est plus la sixième
puissance économique du monde elle
serait devenue la neuvième en croire les
faits me soyez honnête monsieur le
premier ministre si certaines
statistiques s'améliorent
cela est dû avant tout à des facteurs
extérieurs croissance mondiale dynamique
faiblesse des taux d'intérêt prix du
pétrole au plus bas alors non la france
de 2016 ne va pas mieux que celle de
dès lors quand allez vous cesser de
berne est honteusement les français qui
croyais moi ne mérite pas les affronts
répétées de l'autosatisfaction de
monsieur hollande
pour conclure je vous rappelle les
propos de françois hollande en 2006
je cite le 49-3 est une brutalité un
déni de démocratie
une manière d'empêcher le débat
parlementaire merci la parole est à
monsieur michel sapin ministres des
finances et des comptes publics
mais un seul président à museler député
monsieur le député verchères lorsqu'on
fait des comparaisons entre 2012 et 2017
ou 2016
et vous avez raison de vouloir faire ces
comparaisons on les fait complètement
on cite la situation de 2012 l'explosion
du chômage en temps quand l'explosion
des déficits
en cinq ans la perte de compétitivité
en dix ans la perte de capacité à
l'exportation extrêmement rapides et
l'on compare les évolutions que s'est il
passé depuis cinq ans nous avons et nous
avons demandé aux français les efforts
nécessaires pour redresser la france et
dans ses efforts
si vous y avait la nécessité de rendre à
notre économie et à nos entreprises de
capacité d'investissement et monsieur le
député vous le savez l'investissement a
repris en france est derrière
l'investissement il y a la capacité d'en
gauche monsieur débuté on peut toujours
tourner tout en dérision
ça a pu éventuellement nous arriver
aussi mais lorsque le chômage baisse au
premier trimestre de cette année
vous ne pouvez pas faire comme si ça
n'était pas vrai pour ceux qui ont
retrouvé des emplois au cours de ce
premier trimestre c'est une réalité pour
les jeunes dont le chômage baisse
continûment depuis plusieurs années
c'est une réalité
après une augmentation du chômage au
cours des années qui précédèrent sur les
députés ça ne va pas mieux pour tout le
monde chacun le sait est le premier
respect que l'on doit c'est à ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont encore dans la
difficulté mais pour la strophe
les choses s'améliorent réellement et au
lieu d'en faire un débat strictement
polémique
vous devriez mieux faire comme certains
chez vous qui nous disait qu'en savez au
mieux pour la france en terme de
patriotes
je suis heureux de l'être merci la
parole est à madame catherine coutelle
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
en politique comme ailleurs le
harcèlement sexuel est intolérable
mais les élus se doivent d'être
exemplaires vous aussi les députés plus
que tout autre
s'il vous plaît devons la loi notamment
sur l'art seulement les agissements
sexistes une affaire secoue notre
assemblée la justice s'en est saisi je
ne la commenterai pas mais elle doit
contribuer à lever l'omerta qui pèse
encore sur les femmes victimes de
harcèlement et permettent que la parole
se libère et que la honte change de camp
en tant que présidente de la délégation
aux droits des femmes
je veux vous interroger sur
l'application des lois que nous avons
votre temps fort c'est la première loi
du quinquennat et celle de 6 août 2014
relatives au harcèlement sexuel le
conseil avait invalidé celle de 92 car
les définitions n'était pas assez clair
cette loi nous a permis de mieux définir
le harcèlement qui est j'insiste un
délit pour l'ensemble de la société
une proposition de loi qui sera examiné
en juin au sénat et que nous avons
adoptée à l'unanimité propose de doubler
les délais de prescription
mais pour les victimes la difficulté et
surtout de parler et d'apporter la
preuve des faits nous avons travaillé
sur l'inversion de la charge de la
preuve
les victimes ne doivent plus avoir à
prouver mais comme pour les
discriminations elles doivent apporter
des éléments de fait et c'est
l'agresseur de prouver qu'il n'a pas
fait c'est monsieur le premier ministre
pouvez vous nous dire quelles mesures
vous entendez proposé pour renforcer la
lutte contre ce fléau du sexisme
ordinaire qu'est le harcèlement sexuel
et dans tous les domaines de l'action
publique
pouvez vous nous dire si vous entendez
prendre des mesures spécifiques pour les
politiques
et pourquoi pas aboutir à des peines
d'inéligibilité il faut donner un coup
d'arrêt au harcèlement dans la société
et à partie en politique les femmes
veulent être entendus
elles doivent pouvoir parler et voir
justice merci madame ou coutelle la pole
comme dames laurence rossignol ministe
de famille de l'enfance et des droits
des femmes
madame la députée catherine coutelle
soyons clairs leur scellement sexuels
dont chaque femme je dis bien chaque
femme peut être victime sur son lieu de
travail
dans son organisation politique sur son
lieu d'étude dans l'espace public dans
la sphère familiale et amicale
le harcèlement sexuel pourrit la vie
d'effarement esquiver les dragueurs
échapper aux lourdes au aux harceleurs
aux prédateurs être constamment sur le
qui-vive colonise et gaspille trop de
temps de cerveau disponible des femmes
le harcèlement est une violence faite
aux femmes qui a subi ce qui le
subissent et comme les autres violences
le harcèlement un style dans l'esprit de
la victime
le doute sur sa propre culpabilité qu
elle bien pu dire qu elle bien pu
laisser entendre à quel endroit
n'aurais-je pas dû me trouver comment
n'aurais-je pas dumas billets pourtant
les rapports amoureux entre les sexes
entre les hommes et les femmes obéissent
à un principe très simple quand une
femme dit non c'est nous c'est pourquoi
eux
c'est pourquoi depuis c'est pourquoi
depuis 2012
le gouvernement a fait de la lutte
contre le harcèlement sexistes et
sexuelles
une priorité vous les avez évoqué
d'abord avec la réforme du code pénal
qui a inscrit le héros définit le délit
de harcèlement sexuel
ensuite avec le décret de 2015 sur le
harcèlement sexistes et sexuelles dans
les universités ce qui prouve bien que
le harcèlement sexuel n'est le privilège
est l'apanage d'aucun milieu d'aucuns le
et je souhaite vivement que la publicité
des débats données dans les milieux
politiques serbes à toutes les femmes
pour qu'elles s'expriment et à tous les
hommes dans tous les milieux pour qu'ils
s'interrogent sur leurs propres
responsabilités enfin